all right show Geordi buck again with
another fight related video involving
login Paul and case I heard a thump oh
you've got to milk it while it lasts
people honestly I'll be back the Conor
McGregor and [__] football soon so
just you know chill out Logan Paul
fighting in the UFC is this a parallel
universe or could this actually [__]
happen I had a conversation with Brendan
Schaub in the DMZ recently where I was
talking about why I think that JJ versus
Logan is good for fighting in general
and why they were brave to take on the
challenge they did and how a successor
is the point is he recently said on his
shore that Logan could sign for the UFC
now the enemy world went mental
after this sir until comes out saying
don't embarrass our sport like [__] off
you're not welcome here Michael cares I
came up and said you have to fight
cyborgs the female champion if you want
to actually get in the UFC he shouldn't
have said that because Logan would kill
cyborg no offense to the woman like
she's a beast
but anyway sage Northcutt who's probably
a similar size and shape to log and
maybe spit smaller
said he wanted to fight them sage as a
genuine [__] killer to be phased a
hell of a young fighter and I don't
think that Logan should be starting at
that point and tyron woodley the
welterweight champion came out and said
he didn't think Logan could beat CM Punk
recently we'll get over that in a minute
why logon to the UFC makes sense the
dude just sold the same amount of paper
views as George st. Pierre's last fight
UFC you've taken on a lot less skilled
fighters than Logan Paul in the past who
couldn't deliver those numbers why the
foot wouldn't have be interested the
course they will Logan is a division 1
wrestler he was top 5 in Ohio State the
guys learning out the box looked pretty
good in his first boxing fight
is he a pro obviously not but there's
things to work with day generally and
once again CM Punk I'm sorry the broke
was a bag of [__] Logan Paul wouldn't
just beat CM Punk the man could bend him
over and [__] his [__] and CM Punk
wouldn't be able to do a damn thing
about it like let's say I'm Punk get in
the cage with having no fighting
background at all at least Logan is a
genuine athletic beast has a wrestling
and as
in boxing I'm sorry he's already better
than Salem and Isolde pay-per-views I
don't even want longer to do this - no I
mean not personally I think you should
probably go up to the wrestling like waa
or some [__] like that the UFC isn't a
place to mess around and try and be an
entertainer do I think you could win a
world title [__] no to be quite honest
with you unless log and shocks the
[__] world
no a dog but do I think you could go in
the USA and beat fighters of a similar
Korea level to him if they did what they
try to do with CM Punk which is match
him up with an O an old guy or one an
old guy yeah like when you stand next to
Logan Paul the guy is like bigger than
Michael Bisping more ripped he's like a
Luke Rockhold type build like and this
isn't [__] bodybuilding but the guy
has some experience and he's selling
pay-per-view they're gonna be interested
in signing them MMA fans can [__] and
cry about this event all they want I'm
saying boxing fans get so pissed off by
ksi and log and Paul why it's just a
YouTube event
they're not real boxers the only reason
boxing fans are genuinely getting
annoyed is that that event has done
better and will do better than most
actual boxing events this year that
shouldn't be a knock on the youtubers
there shouldn't be you're not gonna [__]
that they don't know what they're doing
they're not real boxers and all these
things that's being said about them that
should be your not on actual boxing
promoters in boxers if you're a real
boxer who's skilled and you can't sell
as many people views as guys who don't
know what they're doing that's your
problem with your career not their
problem so don't [__] [__] and moan
about these guys anymore because quite
honestly I'm [__] sick of it these
youtube boxers are getting more young
guys watching boxing then any boxing
event in the last 10 years I mean that
is the demographic that boxing is
struggling to get more and more because
the UFC have been swallowing that
demographic haul and leaving nothing for
boxing for quite some time so boxing
fans should be grateful for this because
young YouTube fans will be watching this
and thinking god this is entertaining
and these guys aren't even professionals
imagine how good it is to watch some of
the great boxers now they're more likely
to bring you funds that to take anything
away from you guys in YouTube we've
managed to get the two biggest names to
get in a ring with each other and brave
losing and brave the humiliation that
could come with that to put on a show
you
I'll even do that in [__] boxing
Joshua and Wilder won't get in a ring
with each other when they're
professional boxers that's their [__]
job and yet they will get in a ring with
each other and these two youtubers will
you want to worry about boxing and not
[__] YouTube me because it's a
shambles of time I hope that these
events bring young fans to boxing I hope
young boxers look at what these guys are
being able to achieve in marketing
themselves and realize you don't need
Eddie Hood for everything you could
actually build your own profile you look
quite quickly by putting yourself out
there on the internet and being who you
really are which is indicative of why
Tyson Fury and people like that or the
biggest things because their
personalities and that's all these guys
are they've got no fighting skills by
comparison to the top boxers but their
personalities sell the fight and more
box doesn't need to try and do the same
in in the real boxing world everything
is you're sucking at the teat of day now
I already hone hoping that they will
make your career these kids under 25
years old have went and put on their own
event and got a hundred plus thousand
pay-per-view buys like JSP level [__]
and done it on their own like that
should be commended that is
entrepreneurial boss level [__] so if
anyone's got a problem with that you're
just a hater and if you keep watching
something and bitching about it then bet
you're a fan so deal with it it's
frustrating for me because we've been
doing these events football events all
these sort of things nobody cared when
they sold out Wembley for a football
event or whatever as soon as it's boxing
boxing and and fighting they're so
territorial over you can't commit our
sport unless you've been killed in the
gym before and fair enough I respect
fighting so much but let these lads put
on the event and let them do what they
want like I just so I'm [__] clear
and everything I've said yeah I don't
think Logan should go in the UFC
it's a [__] hard sport this guy's
being a vlogger it requires 100%
dedication and I don't know if that's
their move for him personally
boxing wise I think that these guys put
on a great show for what it was and
should be encouraged to keep doing
things that he brick and groaned and not
slated for it that's just my opinion
let us know what you think in the
comments below hit the
button subscribe thanks for watching and
I'll see you later
[Music]